foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI are there enough role
models for people with disabilities the
first ever Barbie doll Down syndrome how
did you feel when you saw it for the
first time so I was excited then I was
embarrassing nothing else on Earth to
hand this dog in my hands
[Music]
and we find out how pupils in Scotland
are unlocking new ways of helping each
other the school started kindness
lockers because they thought people
would need stuff because of the cost of
living crisis
[Music]
hello this is your weekly new share FYI
where we give you the load done on
everything you need to know right now so
first we're going to start off with an
update about something that we've all
been hearing a lot about recently
underage vaping now you may remember
that we made a documentary called FYI
investigates kids who Vape which was all
about the increasing number of young
people trying these cigarettes even
though it's illegal to sell them to
anybody our age
how do you get hold of him because
obviously you're not 18 how do you get
hold of The Vape products so there are
some shops that do sell to under 18s and
I get them off quite a lot of my friends
like my friends they'll be doing it in
school and the toilets and stuff like
that and they can't go a day without
doing it would you say that you're
addicted do you do it a lot yeah I
definitely say I'm addicted like I go
for like two or three a week like
every two or three days after that buy
another one and everything so I do spend
quite a lot of money on it as well well
the government has just announced new
measures to crack down an underage
vaping including more education about
Vapes in our schools I want to make a
difference well Hazel Cheeseman from an
organization called action on smoking
and health joins us now to find out more
hi Hazel hi so thank you for joining us
so what are these things that the
government is trying to do see what the
government has said is that they want to
close the loot poles which we've been
asking them to do for some time
particularly around the fact that
companies can give free Vapes away to
people under 18 uh just as a marketing
tool which was completely unacceptable
when you're not allowed to sell them to
people under the age of 18 and they've
also talked about doing war in schools
and they are considering going further
and looking at things like the promotion
of products and fines on and shops that
sell to people under 18. yeah I mean my
school sent out an email to the parents
about you know the rising issue and how
it's affecting you know the school as a
whole and it was a recommendation to
watch the documentary about vaping to
understand more about it which I thought
was really interesting actually do you
think those measures will make much of a
difference in terms of the numbers of us
who are taking up vaping
but we're not sure that they really will
make a difference unless they do go
further and look at things like
promotion and how much these cheap
disposable Vapes cost because they're
really affordable so we we definitely
like them to go much further so it
doesn't really stop there does it with
government measures so what else would
they be looking to do
yeah but they have a call for evidence
out at the moment which is closing next
week and so you know if you're
interested you can go online and have a
look at that and we really hope that
they take the concerns of the Public
Health Community seriously we really
want them to put attacks on disposable
Vapes probably something like five
pounds to make them a bit more expensive
so if you make them more expensive we
can get them out of schools you know we
can stop people from passing them around
the playground Etc well we can see that
you're super passionate about this so
thank you very much for joining us Hazel
it's been wonderful speaking to you so
if you guys haven't watched the
documentary kids who Vape then make sure
you head over to our webpage at
first.news forward slash FYI
thank you
we all love pizza right but what do you
make of this apparently a certain kind
of Supermarket pizza sold in the UK
contains the same amount of salt as 27
packets of crisps it says fake news or
facts find out later
[Music]
coming up later in the program which
country is doing the best when it comes
to renewable energy we'll have the
answer in just a few moments
now here's an interesting question are
there enough role models for people with
disabilities Ellie Goldstein is a rising
star in the fashion industry she's
modeled for some big Brands like Gucci
and Adidas and has recently become the
first model with Down Syndrome to be on
the cover of the fashion magazine Vogue
Alief says growing up she rarely saw
people who looked like her in the
magazines or on TV which is why she
teamed up with Barbie to launch the
first ever dollar Down syndrome Isn't
that cool and I'm proud to say she's two
of us in the den right now hi Ellie hi
so Ellie the first ever Barbie doll Down
syndrome how did you feel when you saw
it for the first time so I was excited
then I was embarrassing I was honored to
hand it down in my hands of course and
and you've done so many amazing things
haven't you is this right oh yeah of
course of course now how can we tell
this doll is different and has Down
syndrome so if the Dallas got a pink leg
foot support but colors on a dress and
the 21st commercial on the pink necklace
so as we say loads of different parts
that make it the perfect doll yeah
so how do you think this is for raising
awareness about Down syndrome and making
everyone feel included for children
they're being created in a diverse and
in the inclusive event like me perfect
well thank you very much thank you so
much
check this out the ocean bird is an
incredible New Concept for a cargo ship
which is powered by Green energy it will
have sales which are a little bit like
airplane wings and will be powered by
wind which will reduce emissions that
are bad for our environment by 90 cool
and here's something that's already been
built this is a new suspended glass
bottom train in China it's part of an
effort to explore low carbon road
options so it's also a Greener way of
getting about and it can hold over 200
people
[Music]
staying with green energy the UK May
soon have a new multi-billion pound
electric car battery Factory which will
not only create lots of jobs but it's
also good news as it will get more
electric cars on the road which don't
use fossil fuels but what is green
energy and how can it help tackle
climate change well if you just don't
get it don't worry because Maya has been
investigating
[Music]
have you ever thought about how much
energy we use whether it's watching cat
videos on our phones
[Music]
buying a burger from a takeaway
or going somewhere in the car
pretty much everything we do involves
energy
but where does it all come from
well I've been checking this out for
most of human history our energy use has
been pretty low
but over the last hundred years or so
it's skyrocketed quite literally
at the moment most of the energy we use
comes from things like gas oil and coal
they're often called fossil fuels
because they come from the remains of
prehistoric plants and animals these
remains contain carbon which when we
bring it up from underground can be
burnt to make energy and fuel
imagine that we're using dead dinosaurs
to move all our stuff around and
generate electricity crazy
but burning fossil fuels also sends
harmful gases into the atmosphere
causing our climate to change
luckily though there's another type of
energy called Green energy or renewable
energy it creates electricity using wind
turbines and solar panels which use the
heat of the Sun
plus there's also hydropower created by
the flow of water in rivers and oceans
the good thing is these forms of energy
aren't as harmful for the environment
but that doesn't mean there aren't some
challenges
for example what happens when the wind
isn't blowing and what if there's no
sunshine like at night time
well let's talk to an expert one of the
UK's green energy Pioneers Dale Vince
hi Dale so can you solve some of these
problems for us are wind turbines any
good when the wind isn't blowing
well it's a good question and a funny
one because obviously windmills as I
prefer to call them don't go around when
there's no wind but it's not such a big
problem that doesn't happen very often
and when it does we have big cables
connecting the countries of Europe and
we can take electricity from somewhere
where it is windy and give it back when
we have the wind and they don't
and what about all the steel and wind
turbines doesn't that have to be made
with fossil fuels another good question
wind turbines are made from steel and
concrete most things are today but
that's not the problem that it might
appear to be because if you look at the
carbon cost of all of those materials
when you put up one windmill within six
months you've got that back through
carbon savings and for the next 30 Years
you make a net saving of carbon and
steel is beginning to be made without
fossil fuels as well
but what about solar panels when there's
no sunlight
of course solar panels don't work when
there's no sun at night time but that's
not such a big problem people on their
homes today are putting in batteries and
solar panels so that when they make
energy during the day that they don't
need they can keep it and use it at
night
so which country is doing the best with
renewable energy
well I've been looking into this and
let's see if you can guess from these
four which one it is
is it the UK
the USA Norway or India
well
the answer is
Norway
[Applause]
nearly all of its electricity comes from
hydropower created by water flowing down
steep valleys from us high mountains and
guess what they're exporting some of
their Hydro power to the UK using giant
wires across the North Sea
so Dale could we be doing more in the UK
to make sure that we don't use fossil
fuels absolutely there's two things we
could do here one is to use less energy
we can probably save 20 to 25 at home by
turning things off turning things down
like thermostats and meanwhile we've got
50 green electricity on the grid we
could get to 100 in about 10 years we
have enough wind and sun to power the
whole country nearly 20 times over
Innovations for the future so we have a
new way to make electricity something
called a tidal Lagoon using underwater
propellers driving generators that looks
really exciting but up until now we've
only been talking about electricity we
also use a lot of fossil fuel gas to
heat our homes and run businesses we've
found a new way to make that gas from
grass and we have enough grass in the
country to make all of the gas that we
need so that we can free ourselves from
fossil gas completely
thank you Dale
that was my pleasure thank you
so it seems like green energy really is
the way forward if we want to protect
our planet
and before too long the fossil fuels
that we rely on at the moment will
become a thing of the past just like
dinosaurs
[Music]
now how did you get on with this week's
fake news or fact
people have been suggesting that one
Supermarket Pizza could have the same
amount of salt as 27 bags of crisps when
it's a fact research by the organization
action on salt has found that half of
all pizzas sold in the UK provide a
day's worth or more of salt per pizza
and that pizzas provide us with a
whopping
3224 tons of salt every year that's
enough to cover Wembley Stadium's
football pitch
please
we all know that the cost of living
crisis is making things really tough for
families to afford everyday essentials
such as food cloves and toiletries well
how about this for an idea we've been to
Commonwealth Academy in Northland next
year to find out how pupils are working
together to make sure no one is left
without the things they need at home
the king's lockers are almost at a
charity shop where you can take stuff
out of them when you really need them
and then you can put stuff back in in
order for some favor from someone else
want you to sign with a kindness Locker
is Foods they can have drinks best thing
would probably be that there's clothing
in it most donation things would usually
be food or toiletries but we've taken a
step further and have added clothing to
it because no clothing is getting
expensive nowadays as well the skills
started kindness lockers because they
thought people would need stuff because
of the cost of living crisis it helps
make the necess like bar because it
almost brings a form of relief to
families they can get help from their
school you can just go to Any teacher
and they just ask them if you could
borrow a key for any kind of blockers
and they won't even ask why they'll just
like let you borrow the key and you can
just go and take whatever you want our
school has always been one that when you
make sure to treat everyone equal we
decided that they shouldn't be kept
Anonymous you don't need to whatever
asking someone for help and then they
rejecting you it's really no questions
asked I would be just a great way to
help someone you don't even know no
matter what absolutely anyone in this
morning could be struggling I think we
should just share this around different
schools and it would help so many more
people
foreign
[Music]
if you have a story and want to report
for FYI why not set up an FYI news for
about your school you get loads of
resources for your Club so you can
discuss and learn more about their big
stories just get your teacher to head to
our webpage for more details
[Music]
it's nearly it for this week but we
thought we'd leave you with some amazing
images of some newly discovered deep sea
creatures including one called the gummy
squirrel see you next time bye
thank you
[Music]